With the reveal of Gear 5th, we’ve
learned the shocking truth behind Luffy’s
devil fruit - for years, we’ve thought that
he ate the Gum Gum fruit, but in reality he
ate the Human Human Fruit Model: Nika - the
fruit with the most ridiculous power in the
world.
Hook #2: The most ridiculous power in the
world belongs to the most ridiculous main
character in the world - but what if the weakest
members of the Straw Hats had Luffy’s God-like
abilities?
Hook #3: Today we ask the ultimate question:
Would Nami still look as good if she traded
her signature orange hair for Gear 5 Luffy’s
white locks?
With the reveal of Gear 5th, we’ve learned
the shocking truth behind Luffy’s devil
fruit - for years, we’ve thought that he
ate the Gum Gum fruit, but in reality he ate
the Human Human Fruit Model: Nika - the fruit
with the most ridiculous and insane power
in the world.
And throughout the story, it kind of feels
like destiny that Luffy of all people got
to eat this fruit.
In fact, it almost seems like the fruit chose
him and not the other way around.
But what if the fruit had been eaten by someone
else?
What if instead Luffy, it was eaten by a different
Straw Hat?
And we’re not just talking about the already
strongest members of the crew like Zoro or
Sanji eating the fruit - What if the weakling
trio ate the Nika fruit?
Now, for those of you who don’t know, the
weakling trio consists of Usopp, Nami, and
Chopper.
And while these three have their own strengths,
fighting is not necessarily their favorite
thing to do.
In fact, these three are quicker to run away
screaming than to face down a powerful enemy.
But would that change if they had one of the
strongest devil fruits in all of One Piece?
Usopp is probably the likeliest of the weakling
trio to actually come in contact with the
fruit.
After Shanks and his crew stole the Nika fruit
from the World Government, they headed to
Foosha Village in the East Blue.
However, in this alternate timeline, we’re
just going to say that Yasopp the Great decided
to actually go visit his son instead of being
a complete deadbeat.
All it would have taken was the Red-Hair Pirates
making a quick pit stop in Syrup Village and
Bada-Bing-Bada-Boom, we’ve got one stretchy
Usopp.
It’s been kind of insinuated that the Nika
fruit has a will of its own.
Its eluded capture by the World Government
for 800 years, after all.
So, it very much seems like the fruit somehow
chose Luffy - but let’s just say that Usopp
seeing his father filled him with adventurous
spirit and courage and therefore deemed this
future brave warrior of the sea worthy of
its powers.
As we know, the Hito Hito no Mi: Model Nika
appears to be just a rubber fruit before it’s
awakened.
So the first result of Usopp gaining this
fruit is that he’d have a rubber body.
One benefit of this is that his already long
nose could become even longer.
However, the real benefit is that this power
would actually be kind of perfect for Usopp.
He wouldn’t need his slingshot, Kabuto,
anymore.
If Usopp’s entire body was elastic, he’d
BE the slingshot.
Just imagine how sick it would be to see Usopp
in Dressrosa making his coolest shot in the
series - Sugar is about to take Luffy and
Law out of commission and Usopp has to take
her out from miles away.
But this time, instead of firing a round that
looks like his own face…Usopp yeets himself
with perfect observation haki precision.
Beyond being able to fling projectiles (and
himself) super far, though, Usopp’s real
advantage with this fruit might be the durability
that comes with being made of rubber.
After all, few characters can take a beating
like Luffy, especially from blunt objects.
However, the only character that seems to
take even more damage than Luffy and then
inexplicably recover…is Usopp.
Say what you will about the man - he’s not
strong.
He’s not always brave.
But Usopp can take a hit.
This is a guy whose whole skeleton has been
shattered on numerous occasions and then shakes
it off to be walking around in the next chapter.
Now just imagine if Usopp was made of rubber:
he could probably survive beatings from Kaidou
himself.
Would he ever be able to hit hard enough to
actually beat an opponent like that?
Probably not - but it would be near impossible
to knock him out.
But would this cowardly character ever have
what it takes to become Joyboy and awaken
his devil fruit?
Probably not, but this video will be a whole
lot less interesting if he doesn’t, so what
would Usopp do with the powers of Sun God
Nika?
Usopp is a straight up inventor, consistently
making use of technologies like dials to make
weapons like Kabuto and the Clima-Tact.
Having the ability to bring anything in his
imagination to life would make this creative
character super overpowered.
Imagine: an overpowered Usopp.
They said it couldn’t be done.
All of the battles he’s won, he’s had
to do so with his ingenuity to compensate
for his lack of physical strength.
He’s used everything from hot sauce to plants
to a paper-mache version of his own face to
win battles, but with the Nika fruit he could
presumably just…bring these things into
reality without much limitation.
After all, in the Egghead Island arc, we saw
Luffy create actual physical goggles with
his Gear 5 powers - we’re not sure what
the upper limit is, but it seems that this
fruit can just spontaneously create objects.
If that’s the case, then Usopp is sure to
make good use of them.
On the other hand, it’s a bit less clear
how Nami would make use of Luffy’s devil
fruit.
In fact, how would she find it in the first
place?
Well, the time that Arlong came to Nami’s
home village was around the same time that
Shanks brought the Gum Gum fruit to the East
Blue.
So let’s just say that after she joined
up with the Arlong Pirates to protect her
village and began stealing treasure, she found
herself in Windmill Village and lifted the
box from the Red Hair pirates while they were
busy partying.
The problem is, this box didn’t contain
any gold…just a big purple piece of fruit.
She was especially hungry that day, so voila,
rubber Nami.
How would Nami use the fruit?
Well, in its base form when she’s just rubber,
it’s hard to say.
One dark thought that comes to mind is that
it could actually be a disadvantage while
she was still with Arlong.
The Fishmen had no reservations about making
Nami suffer, so they’d almost certainly
use the devil fruit’s weakness to water
as a method of torture…but that’s a little
morbid, so let’s get to the fun stretchy
stuff instead.
Nami could use her newly elastic body to squeeze
into some tight places in order to find treasure…and
then steal that treasure.
While Luffy uses his body almost exclusively
for combat purposes, Nami would figure out
how to turn her new powers into a stealth
tool.
She could access hard to reach places by flinging
herself into places, squeezing into tight
quarters, and so on.
And if she ever was captured, it’d be no
problem for her to squeeze right out of the
bars of her jail cell.
In addition, her mastery of the weather in
combat would gain a huge advantage.
She already loves to summon lightning to electrocute
her opponents, but with Luffy’s rubber body,
Nami could conjure as much lightning as she
wished without any risk of taking damage herself.
Her thunderbolt tempo would be absolutely
insane.
Talk about a shocking development.
If Nami went Gear 5, she wouldn’t even need
the clima-tact anymore because she could just
pull lightning bolts right out the sky willy-nilly.
If Nami managed to awaken the fruit, it would
be…well, fruitful, for her navigation career
as well.
The Grand Line’s seas are absolutely treacherous,
but by using Gear 5’s ability to affect
terrain and make other objects bouncy, she
could just have the Thousand Sunny safely
trampoline its way through the New World with
little regard for the weather.
Depending on how exactly Nika’s imaginative
powers work, she might even be able to stop
storms or reshape the weather itself - but
we won’t know that until we get a few more
answers about what exactly this fruit can
do.
The truly tragic thing, though…would be
that Nami would lose the luscious orange locks
she’s known for.
And that leads us to Chopper, and we saved
the most interesting one of the bunch for
last.
Now, Chopper has next to no reason run into
Shanks and co, so we’re going to say that
in this timeline, Lucky Roo got really sick
on the way back to the East Blue and the Red
Hair pirates had to seek medical attention
on Drum Island.
That big piece of meat he’s always holding
must have finally gone bad and given him a
stomach bug.
For some reason their doctor, Hongo, just
couldn’t cut it this time…Also, it turns
out Shanks has a doctor on his crew: who knew?
However, Dr. Kureha fixed Lucky Roo right
up, but not before a stray reindeer took a
bite of gum gum and turned into the walking
talking reindeer we all know and love.
As we know, our favorite blue nosed reindeer
became super intelligent when he ate the Hito
Hito no Mi: Model…nothing.The plain old
human fruit gave him all the powers of a person,
so we’re going to imagine that the Human
Human Fruit Model Nika will still grant him
that baseline and then some.
He’ll be the same old Chopper we’re used
to…just sillier and stretchier.
The catch is: Chopper would awaken his fruit
waaaaaay sooner than Luffy thanks to a little
thing called the rumble ball.
The rumble ball is a pill that allows Chopper
to alter his zoan fruit transformations to
unlock forms that aren’t just reindeer,
human, or human-reindeer hybrid.
With this he can utilize forms like brain
point, horn point, and guard point - not to
be confused with a point guard.
To my knowledge Chopper has never once played
basketball.
Of course, Sanji got to go to a Food Wars
crossover, so maybe one day Chopper will make
his way into Slam Dunk.
Hopefully not as the ball.
Chopper’s transformations get insane, though,
if he overdoses on his rumble balls: if he
eats three rumble balls at once, things get
real crazy and he transforms into the powerful
Monster Point.
A form that was incredibly cool when we first
saw it and now for some reason has the downside
of making him talk like an old man.
Based on Monster Point’s similarity to the
Impel Down Jailer Beasts, who are theorized
to be awakened devil fruit users, this rumble
ball overdose appears to be able to force
a devil fruit to awaken.
Another piece of evidence for this transformation
is that Bepo, Law’s mink crew mate, was
able to force himself into a Sulong transformation
using a rumble ball.
Mink’s sulong transformations involve the
mink growing stronger and turning white with
red eyes…eerily similar to how Gear 5 Luffy
looks.
The only thing is, Chopper’s monster point
and the Impel Down jailers don’t have the
little cloud ring that Lucci and Luffy have
in their awakened forms.
In Japan, this is meant to resemble this thing
here called a “hagoromo” that many deities
are depicted wearing.
So, there’s a possibility that instead of
achieving true awakening like Luffy, Chopper’s
forced awakening would be some kind of terrible,
bouncy, mindless beast - probably resembling
a sulong mink that can’t yet control the
power of its transformation.
But assuming that the rumble ball trick does
work, Chopper would probably have awakened
the Nika fruit before the rest of the crew
even arrived at Drum Island!
With that kind of power, this reindeer could
have kicked Wapol out of the country for sure,
turning Drum Island’s castle into Dr. Kureha’s
permanent residence.
With Gear 5’s imagination-based powers,
he also could have brought Dr. Hiruluk’s
dream to life and made Sakura trees bloom
on the island.
Forget making the mountain look like a cherry
blossom tree, he probably just could have
gotten them to bloom for real.
And again, we’re not sure what the limits
of this fruit are…but could Chopper use
it to bring his dream to life and cure any
disease?
I’d like to think so, because of how this
fruit truly works, and if you want to have
a complete explanation of how the Nika fruit
actually works and what its abilities really
can do, you can check out my video about it
right here.
Shanks for watching.